hey guys it is Monday and almost August
somehow not sure how that happened but
at least that means it's warming up here
in Australia but you know what's even
cooler than that damn ice cold what no
yeah yeah ice cold it's a video game
news but in video games alright Thursday
kick things up this morning we've got a
couple of stories about giant beasties
for you so that'll be fun but first of
all Ark survival evolved has been
delayed yeah less fun develop a wild
card announce that the final game will
now launch on ps4 Xbox one and PC on
August 29th it was originally set to
arrive on August 8 after being in early
access for over two years wild card have
said the delay is because the process of
going gold and going through
certification quote took a little longer
than expected the company put it fairly
simply saying we're deeply apologetic it
sucks
it wasn't what we had wanted not planned
but it's where we currently stand in
happier news the game's new Ragnarok map
will arrive on console on August 29th as
well the same day as a big PC patch for
the arena lens wildcard said that
Ragnarok will grow in size by 1/4 on
release day and the update will
introduce new biomes a coastal wireman
Canyon and epic boss encounter new
engrams and something secret the
Ragnarok team are cooking up well God
added that their focus will be on PC and
multiplayer updates in the coming weeks
but the update will eventually come to
console as well let's keep these stories
about giant animals rolling as most a
hunter stories is coming to third yes
later this year the next installment in
the long-running game series will be
released exclusively for 3ds on
September 8 monster hunt a story strays
from the established formula of co-op
action into a more colorful turn-based
RPG and you'll be playing as a monster
rider
you'll be able to collect and hatch eggs
use each beasts abilities in battle and
craft weapons and armor the game also
features a variety of side quests and a
multiplayer battle mode there will be a
free demo of monster hunter stories
coming to the 3ds eShop on August 10 if
you decide that something you're
interested in you can transfer your save
data across to the full game when it's
released Nintendo also released a new
trailer which you can check out overrun
games by truly one of my last greatest
regrets was that I never got my hands on
one of those I witnessed the most
powerful console ever made t-shirts at
this year's e3 well every socia Eve's
EMR witnessed the Xbox one X and here
it's gonna change the industry camera
told the GameSpot he's encouraged by the
shift in focus from peripherals like
connect to the internal power of
Microsoft consoles saying we like that
because it means the industry will grow
because the better the experiences the
more people want to have it we think it
has a good potential if Microsoft is
really behind it it can do well PMR
added that Ubisoft upcoming game
Assassin's Creed origins takes good
advantage of the console the Xbox one X
is out this November 7 for 500 clams
with pre-orders opening soon if you're
lucky enough to be heading along to
games come in Germany next month you can
get hands-on with the Xbox one X as well
be sure to let us know your thoughts on
Microsoft's latest console down below in
the comments that's it for GameSpot news
for today make sure you're subscribed so
you don't miss our smiling faces Monday
to Friday and everyone else the smiling
faces for the rest of the time when
they're making video features and all
kinds of cool stuff we will see you guys
tomorrow
the one regret that keeps me awake at
night is the fact that I didn't get an
eye witness the most powerful console
ever made t-shirt while I was at e3
well Ubisoft see Reeves gamer seems to
think that it's really good and perfect